i am uh i have this story from reuters
check this out
trump and 17 states back texas bid to
undo his election loss at the supreme
court reuters reports
president donald trump and 17 u.s states
on wednesday
threw their support behind a long-shot
lawsuit by texas
seeking to overturn his election loss by
asking the u.s supreme court to throw
out the voting results in four states
trump defeated by president-elect joe
biden in the november third election
filed a motion with the court asking the
nine justice justices
to let him intervene and become a
plaintiff in the suit
filed on tuesday or by republican govern
texas against georgia michigan
pennsylvania wisconsin
if the justices let trump join the
lawsuit it would create the
extraordinary circumstance of a sitting
u.s
president asking the top court to decide
that the millions of votes cast in the
four states did not count
the republican president lost to biden
in the four election battleground states
after winning them in the 2016 election
writing on twitter trump said
this is the big one our country needs a
victory
in a separate brief lawyers for 17
states led by missouri's republican
attorney general eric schmidt
also urged the justices to hear the case
election law experts
have said the texas lawsuit stands
little chance of success and lacks legal
merit and i will add as well
we actually had a trump supporting
lawyer on the show will chamberlain the
other day
who also didn't think it was going to
make it so take that with a grain of
salt i know a lot of people are excited
by this
and i think outside of that there's
political ramifications as to why i
think they will end up taking this but
i'm not a lawyer the reuters goes on to
say the lawsuit the latest in a series
of election challenges brought by
trump's campaign
and supporters that so far have failed
in numerous courts
was brought by ken paxton the republican
attorney general of texas
and an ally of the president here we go
in addition to missouri the states
joining texas were
alabama arkansas florida indiana kansas
louisiana mississippi montana nebraska
north dakota oklahoma south carolina
south dakota tennessee utah and west
virginia all of the states were
represented by republican officials in
the filing
all but three of the states have
republican governors they go on to say
trump has made false statements etc etc
but i think we got the gist of the story
and i'm just going to say i wouldn't be
surprised if the other republican states
of which i think
by by uh state houses we have what 29
states that are republican
i don't see why they all wouldn't sign
on either except i think you know
uh the states that are actually being
sued who are republican as well so that
means there's 25 states
that could potentially sign on
supporting this lawsuit now as of right
now my understanding is
they've just filed for leave which means
they're asking permission
to sue we'll see if it happens but um
this is kind of crazy the president is
joining republican states
suing four states that went for biden in
order to win the election
is this uh civil war was it wait well
it's not civil war but this is one
third of the united states saying that
they are contesting the election this is
significant and we'll see how it plays
out in the supreme court a lot of people
have their different opinions on this
but this shows you how this country is
divided
and how this divide is going to keep
growing very bad yes
i mean it's you know look years ago i
was talking about the violence in the
streets
antifa proud boys and stuff and people
were saying
you know i was like i feel like we're on
the trajectory for a civil war i feel
like it's possible
because you have growing tribal factions
you have the culture war which became
political when it reached you know
politicians
then we started seeing you know populist
left fabulous right getting into
positions uh federal positions getting
elected so now it's in government now
it's in the presidency
now it's in the supreme court and now
you have the states lining up this is
crazy earlier today i was like when you
have
five states you know lining up against
four states we're starting to see the
states draw those lines
this is this this to me is nuts if 17
states are basically saying joe biden
shouldn't be president
what happens if joe biden becomes
president how are these states going to
function
we also had the the uh the oath keepers
the largest militia in the country their
founder said
uh his uh
he said that half the country will not
view anything
out of uh joe biden's mouth as a
legitimate that he's not the president
so this is getting spicy well there's
going to be a lot of 10th amendment
arguments that a lot of sheriffs and a
lot of local politicians kind of trying
to stand their ground and we're going to
have another big battle
as we've seen under the bill clinton
presidency between the states and the
big federal government
where we saw large incidences like waco
and ruby ridge i mean
a lot of people are talking about the
worst of the worst i don't know some
people are trying to be more pragmatic
saying maybe it won't be that bad but
just from your kind of expertise
politically how do you see these things
moving forward because some people are
saying there's going to be a big clash
there's going to be a big fight some
people are saying
well no one's really going to care
everyone's going to go back to normal
how do you see it from your kind of
political expertise
i think that right now everybody is
anticipating
the worst possible scenario i think
first of all it's very fear-based
thinking and that's something that we
all like to do i think people are very
into their labels
they're very into teams this is very
tribalist and so
people are sort of doubling down now did
those same people
have the actual you know wherewithal to
follow up with that to actually
do something does this actually go
anywhere does this hit the streets does
this become
i don't know like i don't think so i
think that
um depending on what happens with this
legally will kind of determine where it
goes
and yeah there's going to always be a
contingency of people that are going to
say this is illegitimate
well you voted for biden i
it's one of those things like i am not
the person that's going to stand here
and argue for that
right it wasn't i could just as easily
have not like i went back and forth it
wasn't
like a good this was not an easy choice
it's not something you're proud of
you know i didn't vote for uh trump or
hillary in 2016. i didn't either
and i think it's because on policy
issues i lean left on a lot of policies
so did you go
i i voted green in 69 oh and 2016 i
didn't vote oh okay i put my feet up on
the desk i was hanging out
do you know cassandra fairbanks no she's
uh she's still a trump supporter right
yes oh yeah
but uh i was hanging out with her she
used she was a progressive
like that i think that year right 2016
and then she flipped because i think a
lot of because of the wokeness
she it went from her being as big
activists supporting progressive causes
and social justice issues to being
attacked because
i guess they call her passing white even
though she's you know puerto rican or
whatever
so she ends up becoming a trump
supporter i'm hanging out with her i put
my feet up on a desk
i'm just laughing as as the results come
in seeing hillary clinton lose it was
like
it was comeuppance for the democratic
party for the dirty games they played
well i never supported her there was no
universe where and i was voting for
hillary clinton
that wasn't happening my i mean it
really came down to for me
in that election i voted green i'm
always as opposed to abstaining
um you know any support of third parties
if we can get third parties to get five
percent so
so really that would and you know jill
stein was fine like i didn't you know if
i could actually what was
the the determining factor that made you
vote for biden but not for hillary
what was that decision because it's
interesting to really deep dive into
these things and understand what went
behind this
okay so i like i said i am about the
policies i
despise both of those people in terms of
policy let's be
like there is no i have no delusion
about joe biden
um really what it came down to for me
was when trump
basically signaled to the prowlboys and
again it's theater and it's hyperbole
i'm not saying like oh he hurt my
feelings this isn't that i'm not those
people and when he indicated that he
wouldn't support a peaceful transition
of power
and that is a problem for me because
there's something i do believe in is our
constitution so i take that seriously so
when it comes to a lot of things i am
very live and let live
the fact that he was seemingly to me
directly threatening basically the
foundation
of the what is our process that was not
okay with me
i i never um
it was never about joe biden i he's
don't you think hillary clinton did that
the democrats did that
and i know you're not a big fan of the
establishment politicians no no you know
for four years
i guess the argument from the right is
for four years they accused trump of
literally being an agent of russia they
spent 30 million
doing this this investigation which
turned out nothing they ended up going
after i think the prosecution of michael
flynn is
is nightmarish when you look at all the
details and then so trump basically is
like
why am i going to give them the courtesy
that they didn't give me i
i agree but this is one of those what
about ism things right so i'm
as an adult i am dealing with what i
have in front of me right now
i have never supported hillary clinton i
find her despicable
for so many reasons like we i could
write a dissertation i wonder if
everyone's cheering in the chat right
now like hillary's awful everybody hates
her
no she's horrible she's a horrible
person i think we all agree on that yeah
no she is a horrible person um i find
her infinitely more
nefarious than i find joe biden
i find him more hapless i find him just
he's just a tool he's an establishment
tool i find hillary to be quite
nefarious but but kamala harris is the
actual
kamala is hillary right right so you
voted for kamala
well i didn't and i plan on spending the
next four years of my life like making
sure that there's a really decent
primary challenge i mean i
and i have been very clear that there is
no universe see for the same reason i
find hillary nefarious i find kamala
nefarious
i don't find joe biden nefarious and if
he's the pause button
like i view him as the pause button but
we still need to get our
stuff in order yeah
but we do and it's and it's a serious
problem so no and i don't see him
as solving anything but i think come on
joe biden's
on the way out i'm not trying to be mean
or not but i nancy pelosi
you know created that commission or
whatever of presidents also on her way
out
yeah well yeah i certainly hope so i
can't believe that she keeps winning but
anyway she creates this commission about
removing a president if they're not
cognitively fit or whatever and
everyone's like you're trying to get rid
of trump and she goes
no no it's for a future president no no
they're wanting to install kamala that's
that's been their goal for the past four
years they were sticking her there one
way or the other
i mean i didn't even talk about i won't
i can't even say that i wouldn't
necessarily i really can't say again
like when i made that decision this is
not something where i'm
again like i wish i could tell you i
defend that and this
i don't i really don't it really could
have been a coin toss on the day that i
did it
you know i don't i i i hear you're
saying i've met a lot of people
um one of the stories i tell a lot is i
was in i was i went on glenn bex i was
in texas where's he and he's in austin
or something
and i was in an uber on the way to the
studio and the guy was driving was
uh the child of immigrants he i he asked
me what i was doing i said i was going
to glenn back and he was like oh yeah
yeah politics and stuff like that he's
like so so you're a trump trump
supporter at the time i was like no no i
think the media lies about him i don't
think he's that bad but i'm not
and he's like yeah he he said i voted
for him and you know man i just wish he
would
stop talking and stop tweeting the way
he does because it's like
it's hard to defend sometimes you know
and i'm like this is a regular guy who's
driving uber who likes the president but
is having an issue with the president's
character and the things he says yeah
particularly around like
you know we'll see what happens with the
election and stuff i personally don't
think it was the most bombastic thing he
said
in terms of we'll see how it plays out
you know not a peaceful transition or
whatever we'll sue and
now it's certainly not a a yeah well i
don't know if it's
you can't call it peaceful it's going
through the course we don't know yet the
truth is we don't know
what's going to happen come you know
what is it january 21st
i'm i'm kind of scared i'm i
i don't think there's a way out i don't
think look well he keeps building the
fence higher
well oh yeah but that's a meme too the
wall just got two feet higher
uh joe biden's son is now they're
announcing this what is this that the
they've said that he's under criminal
investigation or
tax investigation i mean there's there's
so much there
and it's crazy that the story broke of
course it was an october surprise
and twitter suppresses it facebook
suppresses it the the big news outlets
won't cover it
and now we get this video i don't know
if you saw the video where there's a
chinese professor uh d
dong shang where he basically said the
bidens are compromised
yeah and he was like who do you think
got hunted by all that money
so i look at you know donald trump and i
see the peace agreements
that have come through in the past
several months i like it he's trying to
withdraw the troops from afghanistan and
he's being blocked by both democrats and
republicans
i don't like this my congress person
couldn't get behind that so i understand
that and that's somebody with a nice big
d
behind her name she couldn't support
withdrawing from afghanistan why
she couldn't even get behind reducing
the pentagon by ten percent this is
debbie wasserman
oh she's awful she's hillary that's what
i'm saying so you know when people start
looking at the
the letters uh i would urge them to look
at the policy choices
i'm i'm i i am actually fearful that a
joe biden presidency
is yeah he's hapless but he's he's he's
going to sell us out
like the the the obama administration
you're familiar with the trans-pacific
partnership
yes i know the tpp and i imagine you're
opposed to it of course but joe biden is
going to bring us all back into this of
course
but but i also think and i hope that he
gets us back into the iran deal because
for the same reasons that
i was applauding trump in terms of when
he was going into north korea and of
course the democrats were all you know
they were trying to they attack him from
the right all the time it's infuriating
we'll see
as the true left because i'm the we
don't like that so
that's you're attacking him for the sake
of attacking him you're attacking him on
the few things that we might
actually come to agreement on and so i
do like the idea of getting back into
the iran deal
um that is something that i support so
you know he in the similar way was going
to undo everything obama did they're
going to tulsi gabbard you
call you right wing and all this stuff
they can't except for my policies speak
to the complete laughter like i
don't care well you know i guess it
depends on who you say are they
who's that the media establishment the
democratic system they ignore me anyway
the truth is and here's you want to know
if something ever was going to protect
me
is that what benefits debbie wasserman
schultz best is if i'm completely
ghosted
if my name comes up and i come up then
that's going to draw attention to that
race to that district to her and that
never benefits her
so i am more at risk of being completely
ghosted
than i am of being trashed luke once
yelled at debbie wasserman schultz yes
we asked her some very serious questions
about obama's kill list which she told
me face-to-face didn't exist
this was big news though because
everyone knew it existed new york times
said it existed yeah
obama was signing off every tuesday on
who they were going to kill and then
she's like that's that's not a real
thing
and everybody was like whoa she's lying
she was the head of the dnc
and she of course and people forget she
had to resign in disgrace
from the dna oh then our district
re-elected her yes and then
hillary clinton took her under her claws
right afterwards and literally and
literally broadcasting
with a w or a u i'm not even gonna get
in there
brought her in and gave her a job right
away so yeah so
uh yeah definitely washerman schultz
isn't a fan of mine either but
you know there's a lot to learn from
each other thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you